we have finally got it the 14 inch
macbook pro with the m1 max processor so
we can compare it to the 16 inch and
answer the biggest question once and for
all how much performance do you lose
with the smaller chassis the smaller
fans the smaller heatsinks and without
the high power mode on the 16-inch
macbook pro and i am not going to go
easy on these machines now as a bonus i
have both these machines at 100 battery
life so as we go through these tests
i'll be giving you guys updates on how
the battery life is doing and how much
longer the 16 inch will last with its
larger battery compared to the 14 inch
which also will likely have to spin up
its fans more so draining more power now
right now both of the fans are off and
the idle temps surprisingly are exactly
the same they keep bouncing between one
or two degrees of each other so there's
no difference there just yet and of
course we're going to do a wide variety
of tests stressing both the cpu but
mostly focusing on gb performance
because that is what the 32 core m1 max
offers over the m1 pro let's go ahead
and unplug both these bad boys and begin
the first thing i'm going to do is run
geekbench 5 cpu test to see if we have
any differences but i don't expect any
and here you go the results are
practically identical and the fans
stayed off on both machines the whole
time and now let's run the compute test
which does a bunch of various metal
accelerated tasks and some of you may
know that geekbench doesn't use the full
gpu performance but i wanted to run it
to see what kind of peak wattage we get
and if we see any differences between
the 16-inch with the high-power mode
allowing a bit more power or faster
power ramping for graphics and here you
go the test is done and this is
interesting the 14-inch actually hit a
higher peak of 36 watts compared to 33
watts and here are the results we have
69 000 for the 16 inch which is actually
the highest we've gotten and 67 000 for
the 14 inch just slightly lower
performance but that's only in geekbench
5. i realize the backgrounds are going
to be annoying that they're the same so
let's swap that background over and
let's jump into the next test that's
going to push these machines and that is
cinebench and the reason i'm running
this is to see if that high power mode
affects the cpu performance at all
between the 14 inch and the 16 inch or
if it's only the gpu we're almost at the
end of the run and surprisingly the cpu
frequencies are basically identical at
least so far in this 100 load we have
the results from the first run and the
14 inch is actually about 50 points
higher than the 16 inch i'm gonna go
ahead and run a few more tests just to
allow them to heat up more so and see if
we slowly start throttling on the
14-inch and the 16-inch can still run
faster with that mode now we're on our
fifth front and so far everything's been
very consistent the only difference is
that the 16 inches fans are running
slightly above idle they were pretty
much idle almost the whole time until
this fifth run whereas the 14 inch as
you guys see they're about two thirds of
the way up about 4 300 rpm
and this one i can hear it but it's
still very quiet and for the final
results the 14 inch is still about 50
points ahead of the 16 inch so no the
high power mode does not affect cpu
performance at all so let's close this
down and jump into gpu tests we're gonna
use 3dmark to max out the graphics and
i'm going to switch back to automatic
power mode when i do this first run and
then afterwards we'll switch it to high
power mode and see if there's a
difference alright guys wow we're seeing
stuff
already we have our results here and
even in the automatic mode the 16 inch
still gave us
121.4 frames per second compared to the
14 inch which gave us a hundred and
eight point eight that is a difference
of eleven and a half percent in favor of
the 16 inch now i'm going to go ahead
and run this one more time in high power
mode that way we can see if there's a
difference i know it's going to be close
and i'll run it again on the 14 inch
just for the sake of our battery life
comparison all right very interesting
looks like our 16 inch went down
slightly in performance with high power
mode and the 14 inch did slightly better
this time but the difference is still
roughly 10
now there's two things that i'm very
curious about first
does the gpu run slower as far as
frequency or wattage with the 14 inch
and second could it be that for the 14
inch if you want the full performance
you actually have to plug it in which is
unlike any other mac ever let's go ahead
and run this and we're going to watch
the wattage and the frequency look at
that our 16 inch is running at
1249 megahertz compared to about a
thousand one hundred and thirty on the
14 inch and look at the wattage the 16
inches getting 43.3 watts compared to
only
35.39 watts on the 14 inch this proves
the apple is intentionally throttling
the 14 inch even if it's not hot now i
haven't seen anybody show these findings
yet online we had to wait for our 14
inch to come in the mail but i want to
run this one more time plugged in so i'm
plugging both in
just so we are doing this fairly and
let's see if that changes on the 14 inch
if it can beat that peak wattage now
that has a power source and look at that
the frequency is still
limited to just over 1100 megahertz and
the wattage did not change it went
slightly higher but insignificantly
compared to the full 1.3 gigahertz with
the 16 inch model so what is gonna
happen once we're doing an extended
workload when the systems heat up is
this thing going to be limited even more
let's go ahead and find out with our
extreme stress test which is going to
run for about 20 minutes now i know this
is a gaming graphics benchmark but it
does show us the full performance of the
gpus compared to other tasks we will do
some video editing another test here in
just a bit and we're on our second loop
now and this is crazy the fans are
actually spinning
louder and the system is hotter on the
16 inch now that is because right now we
are averaging
42 watts of use on the graphics here the
32 core m1 max compared to just
averaging 23 watts on the 14 inch
and because of that it's actually
running a little bit quieter and
slightly hotter on the cpu but the fans
are kicking up now we'll give it a few
more runs but the power draw difference
is crazy now i understand why apple
might want to limit the 32 core m1 max
on the 14 inch obviously we have you
know thermals we have those smaller fans
i showed you but we also have that
smaller battery as well
and with the smaller battery they just
might want to save power they might want
to give you better battery life and of
course in our first run we saw that we
had a difference of about 11 and a half
percent performance but it used about 22
percent less power so that's a pretty
good trade-off for performance while
saving a good amount of battery life now
here's something else that nobody has
told you yet on the internet
actually two tidbits
first off the fans in the 14 inch model
they actually spin faster we have a
maximum of
6241 rpm compared to 5776
on the right side fans and then on the
left side the 14 inch fans also run
about 400 rpm faster and the second
thing is that even if the fans are
running slower on the 16-inch than the
14-inch they actually are louder on the
16-inch just because of how much air
volume is going through that cooler
which i also did not expect now it's
been about 10 minutes everything gets
kind of stabilized but earlier on the
fans were running much higher on the 16
inch because it got too hot and it was
trying to cool it down
and then it was just so much louder than
the 14 inch and then now after
everything settled it's actually running
cooler on the 16 inch and still slightly
louder but the fans have a lot more
headroom if we throw in extra cpu usage
now with that said the 14 inch is
already throttling the gpu even more
than before we saw it ran at 1100
instead of 1300 megahertz but constantly
throughout this stress test we are
literally running between 950 to 1000
megahertz compared to the full
performance not throttled on the 16-inch
so that is already
a little bit disappointing now what i
want to do is i'm going to go manually
hit max on the fans just to see if we
can get full performance by maxing out
those fans because we have a little bit
of headroom here and we see that apple
is choosing the throttle of the 32 cores
instead of running the fans at full
speed just to keep it cool and it looks
like nope even with the fans maxed out
at 6200 rpms
we're still not getting any more
performance still fluctuating in that
range now what is gonna happen if we
introduce a cpu load as well which
happens in some really intensive tasks
like editing ak video and other tasks
where you're pushing both not just the
graphics we're gonna see in just a bit
now accidentally close 3d mark incorrect
way i want to see the scores so i'm
letting it run a few more times before
that but we do see that the 16 inch
under extended load it was using about
60 percent more power for the graphics
to get better performance and under the
on-screen extended stress test we saw a
difference of over 16 percent and now
let's start that cinebench and i think
this is going to get ugly all right guys
look at that so now the gpu is running
at 700 megahertz compared to about a
thousand or 1100 megahertz on the 16
inch but the crazy thing is that under
this load the 16 inch is being throttled
much more than before while apple is
still not choosing to max out the fans
on this thing but slow down the graphics
so let's go ahead and jump into some
other more real world tests than maxing
both systems out and testing out their
cooling obviously we know if you're
gaming you definitely are going to get
better performance on the 16-inch and
while we do that let's go ahead and take
a look at the battery life throughout
all this crazy testing pushing these
machines our 16 inch is still at 33
after hours of testing and the 14 inch
go ahead and guess down below what it's
at let's take a look and it is at 16
so we still have maybe about double the
battery life on the 16 inch but it's not
as big of a difference as i expected and
of course we know now that is because
apple is throttling the graphics on the
14 inch to save battery life and now
let's test out blender i have party tug
opened up right here which uses the
graphics to render and let's see if a
quick render like this will make a
difference as far as everything else
that we found so far i do have both
machines plugged in because the 14 inch
was close to being out of battery and
look at that we have 6.03 seconds
compared to 6.02
of course this is only a six second
render but the graphics were maxed out
and the performance was the same let's
make this a little more difficult i'm
going to add on a lot more effects and
this time the cpu was used more so but
we have almost identical scores 24
seconds for the 14 inch compared to
24.33
for the 16 inch so why in the world are
we now getting the same performance well
if we take a closer look it looks like
for a blender
neither machines are going above 24 25
watts so the artificial limitation that
we saw that apple put on the 14 inch
earlier it's not being exceeded anyways
and that might be because blender
doesn't use metal yet apple is working
with them for that so for the graphics
related tests it's using the older open
gl and now let's get into some video
editing that's going to use the encoders
the cpu and the gpu and before i jump
into this project that's over 30 minutes
long i want to say if you guys enjoy
this content please hit that subscribe
button down below we're trying to reach
our goal of 1 million subscribers before
the end of the year that would be
amazing if we had your support and if
you're a fan check out our merch down
below we have this shirt in a lot of
different colors it's very subtle and
looks great in black we have hoodies and
a bunch of other stuff we would greatly
appreciate it now let's go ahead and
play back and this project here it
should play back great on both these
machines this is our comparison against
the razer blade with rtx 3080 and with
links this long and different animations
grass effects it definitely takes a hit
on our imac that has 16 gigs of ram and
the m1 so what i'm going to do is go
ahead and export this i'm using hevc
that way we're not limited by the
encoders and we give the graphics the
maximum amount of work that it can and
we are off with the graphics cards being
completely maxed out on both so we're a
little over halfway done and it's very
interesting to see that for this test
the graphics card will max out and then
it will drop down a little bit and kind
of take a little bit of break it's
probably done enough work and we might
actually be limited by encoders still
and then it'll kick back up and the cpu
is only running at roughly 20 or so
percent and because of that it's
incredible to see how cool and quiet
these machines run the cpu is not maxed
out the gp is not maxed out so apple did
a crazy job with those insane decoders
and encoders which makes us run so
efficiently and now we're about 70 or so
percent through
and basically the only difference i'm
seeing is that the fans are on the
16-inch they're literally at the slowest
speed possible and we're at 68 degrees
celsius on the cpu 64 on the gpu
compared to
about maybe about 25 of the weight on
the 14 inch and that's running hotter 79
cpu 77 gpu and we are done and that is
just incredible how a 4k project with
graphics and effects and different stuff
that's graded that's 30 minutes and 46
seconds long finished in eight minutes
and 50 seconds on one machine 851 on the
other literally one second of a
difference while being so cool and quiet
that is just insane
just that performance is
more than enough to do this so we're
gonna have to make it even more
difficult and that just shows us that
hey if you're video editing and you're
working on stuff that the encoders and
decoders can handle
we're not seeing that much of a
difference graphics wise with normal
projects that regular people do but what
happens if we make a little tougher now
i'm exporting a five minute prores raw
4k project and this one is pretty much
pinning the gpus and because of that
we're starting to see some of the
difference in graphics performance that
we found earlier wow that was incredibly
quick for a five minute pro res raw
project of course they have encoders in
these systems for prores and the result
is 46 seconds for the 16 inch and 49
seconds for the 14 inch that's a
difference of about seven percent uh so
if you had a longer project not five
minutes or you had more effects that
would be you know longer times savings
and of course the systems did not heat
up in this test because of just how fast
it was able to do that so now let's go
ahead and open up an ak prores raw
project now here i have stacks of 4k in
the 8k timeline creating pretty much ak
prores raw that has to be debayered um
decoded and then one obviously have
effects and luts on there for encoding
let's go ahead and play both of these
back
and this is just crazy performance from
a laptop right here it looks like we're
using about 75 of the graphics on the 16
inch 73 on the 14 inch
73 over here as well so even with 8k
prores raw stacks of an ak timeline
real time deburring this adding the
color grading we're not maxing out
either graphics so because of that we're
still probably not seeing any difference
because this is able to give us the full
performance and that is just mind
blowing now this is editing of course
maybe if you added a little more effects
maybe i can make it even more different
but we're making it as difficult as
possible let's go ahead and export this
8k five minute project and let's see the
difference and bam you can see that the
graphics are being pinned right now the
systems are starting to heat up and the
fans are gonna have to kick in and we
might see some throttling on the
inch the fans on the 14 inch are pinned
to the max whereas a 16 inch is only
about halfway and the export is done and
we do see a difference the 16 inch took
2 minutes and 54 seconds compared to
three minutes and 26 seconds for the 14
inch so that's a difference of over 18
percent and that is because the graphics
were pinned and in that case when i
looked at how much power they're using
the 16-inch was using pretty much double
the power of the 14-ish so it can hit
higher clock frequency so it's a lot
more power there
for not a huge difference of performance
but if you do want the best performance
that is bigger than we even saw in our
first short-term gaming test and even i
think even the throttling gaming test
was about 16 percent difference or so
now this does have encoders and that's
why i was so fast for 8k programs raw
five minutes being so quick to export
now let's do a test where it's going to
push more of the cpu as well as the gpu
we'll do one last test here this is 8k
canon raw in an ak timeline that is
graded and i have to play it back in
better performance mode in order to even
play it or else
it is just choppy so let's export this
five minute project and as you see both
our cpu and the gpu are being hammered
right now wow 103 degrees celsius on the
cpu on the 16 inch graphics at 91
while the fans are ramping up 105
celsius that's crazy even the 16 inch
can get that hot with the craziest tests
and while our 14 inch is getting hot
it's not getting that hot because it is
being power throttled for the graphics
all right guys we have our results the
16 inch took seven minutes and 42
seconds to export this five minute
project maxing out the cpu and gpu
whereas the 14 inch m1 max took 10
minutes and four seconds that is 31
faster
for the 16 inch
model so that is actually the biggest
difference we have seen now i also went
ahead and turned off the high power mode
set it to automatic and exported and it
didn't seem to make any difference at
all
the export actually finished faster
by just a few seconds about 6 seconds
faster than before which is crazy and
the crazy thing is the fans were only up
halfway even though the cpu was at 103
degrees celsius and the graphics at 91.
at that same time exporting again on the
14-inch the results were the same and
just the fan is at full blast trying to
keep everything hot whereas a 16 inch i
wonder why it's not ramping up more so
maybe it knows that there's no
throttling going on anyways so it
doesn't have to run the fans at full
blast in order to do that
i'm not really sure so i'm not really
sure what the high power mode really is
for maybe i'll try the prores
version one more time since mkbhd said
he did get a difference alright guys so
i ran that test i saw no difference i
unplugged the machine i ran the test
again i saw no difference with the high
power mode versus the automatic mode and
then i went back to this crazy ak test
that just punishes the machine and i had
it unplugged this time not plugged in
with automatic code unplugged on battery
i ran it and then i finally saw a
difference and instead of being fast
taking 7 minutes and 40 seconds it took
just over 10
minutes
and so that pretty much matches up with
the performance of the 14 inch plugged
in so basically the only time that high
power mode matters is one
only if you're on battery power and two
only if your application maxes out the
cpu and maxes out the gpu just like what
um mkbhd saw in his red to prores test
but if your graphics card is maxed out
but the cpu is at 50 or 60
and you're on battery power it still
doesn't make any sort of a difference
now if i had a 16 inch i would still
enable it to make sure i'm getting full
performance if i'm on battery just like
max have done for years so technically
now we know that this is the only
machine
that will limit you if you only get the
high spec and you max everything out and
you're on battery you might see a
difference and unless you toggle that
mode which i probably would toggle it
because most of the time it doesn't make
a difference anyways so there you guys
go what is the final verdict on the m1
max between the 14 inch and the 16 inch
well we believe that we thought that
we're gonna get worse battery life in
the 14 inch and we did we saw that
difference at the start
but it wasn't as bad as i expected and
that is thanks to apple uh down clocking
and undervolting the graphics in this
machine to help with that battery life
now i also wasn't expecting as big of a
difference in performance so in the
smallest cases if you're just running
the graphics card and we're not
thermally limited by the cpu you're
getting around 11 difference but in
longer term tests let's say if you're
gaming or doing something else it goes
up to about 16 percent difference in
performance and then if you're just
punishing the machine you can see up to
36 performance difference between a 14
inch and a 16 inch and in that case if
you need the best graphics performance
we now know that you absolutely should
go with the 16-inch model because that
gives you between 11 to 36 percent
better performance and of course better
battery life if you go with this larger
size for 200
more now with that said if you are
somebody that really wants the 14 inch
for the compact size this is the first
time ever you can match up spec respect
between a large one and a small macbook
pro well if you don't push your machine
that much or use short bursts of you
know high-intensity workloads or you're
doing video editing with different
encoders or you're doing blender you
could definitely get away with the
14-inch it might be a little bit worse
performance
or about the same if you're not pushing
it hard so there you guys go we found
multiple different things that i have
not seen anybody else mention or find
and this is our main verdict for these
machines with an m1 max now we also are
going to be covering
uh 32 gigs compared to 64 gigs so if
you're interested in that video make
sure you click that circle above to
subscribe and to help us reach our goal
of a million subscribers check out one
of those great videos right over there
that's been max and i will see you in
the next video
[Music]